good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy oh oh oh
Friday Friday you gotta get down on
Friday
everybody's looking forward to the
weekend weekend Friday Friday Shawn
October Friday
it is the start of a new year tonight
it's Rosh Hashanah which is so exciting
it's a beautiful holiday
symbolizing New Beginnings The Hills New
Beginnings yes that is what it
symbolizes symbolizing renewal rebirth I
actually just read like a little
um newsletter about Rosh Hashanah about
how it's the head of the year right and
it sets the tone for the year okay so
what tone are we setting Thanksgiving
like January 1st how you spend New
Year's Eve is how you'll spend the rest
of the year but the way it was said in
in what I read said it was kind of like
Rosh Hashanah it's the head rosh's head
Hashanah is the year so it's the head of
the year just like your head on your
body like controls your body and makes
the decisions and it's right right head
of this household Rosh Hashanah is the
head of the year so how you spend it
really is going to dictate and set the
tone for the year so how are we spending
it this year what Vibes are we putting
out okay we're spending it with family
yeah which is always great yep we're
spending it vlogging
true and working true so it's a good
thing a good tone to say yep having fun
uh-huh eating good teeny Vibes teeny
Vibe togetherness Streisand lie sand is
here oh actually no I'm spending the
arosha now without my husband
the whole year and you're spelling
spending without Theo but I do have a
little treat for you the Theo pillow oh
because also it will balance out the
frame because if I'm sitting with a
Streisand you need to be sitting with
this dry sand no one will know that he's
not here because he doesn't move usually
these are toast her story oh
speaking of just her story speaking and
this is how we're gonna start the rest
of the Year this is how we're gonna set
the tone for the Year by being number
one
okay so I have my Theo pillow and now we
can finally talk about what happened to
us yesterday yeah kind of an amazing
thing but it didn't happen to us we made
happen I just feel like being so passive
about it like it could happen to anyone
like a chance we're talking about it
like as if Apple did it for us they did
it in spite of us yeah as if we haven't
been working geared towards this goal we
have just always been like lingering at
the top of the podcast charts three
maybe sometimes two never number one
never and what happened yesterday I was
just scrolling doing my hourly checking
on the charts literally hourly and what
do I say droopy Drew in Jets be Jetson
number one number one smartless our
enemies
not even number two not even number
three number four
embarrassing and that is something we
predicted would happen just like a
another Fallout of the the strike
yeah but they couldn't have anyone
fabulous on
I know we're supposed to be in
solidarity with the strikers but now
like seeing how it benefits us seeing
how it benefits us it's hard it's hard
I'm being pulled in a million directions
but I guess that's kind of the whole
point of the strike is making hard
decisions right not for us no it's not
even hard strike all the way strike all
the way keep on striking no actually
Strike It To The Man Jackie it's not
hard because we're standing in
solidarity with the strike yeah but like
the strike it's hard but we have our own
reasons no but I guess the strike itself
is a conundrum because it's like
striking the ability to strike is a good
thing but having to go on strike is a
bad thing so it's like are we Pro strike
or anti-strike we here's what it is and
are the even like as you know everyone
who supports sag after they want the
strike to be over are they Pro Striker
anti-strike they're Pro Strikers but
they don't want to be on strike
everybody wants to get back to work yeah
no it's a it's an interesting kind of
German you bring up it is but all we
know number one in comedy yesterday
thank you to everyone who listened also
it was because our episode was Audio
Only so really the Stars aligned it was
beautiful and just in time for Rosh
Hashanah just in time for Rosh Hashanah
and that means we're gonna spend the
year being number one which is not like
a bad way to spend the year you know
being number three was a pretty good way
to spend the year I'm not gonna lie it's
true and I feel like we might come to
find that it's Lonely at the Top
it's actually not because we were
texting we're together and we were
texting with Heather McDonald who also
she's always number two three right
around us and this morning we were not
number one anymore but Heather was so
you know what it's really not Lonely at
the Top because we have each other and
we have Heather McDonald that's true but
it's like we've been at number three and
we've had this goal ahead of us and
things have been good and I feel like
maybe
you know it's like when you hit the top
where else is there to go it's a long
way down it is also it's important
actually and not being sarcastic like to
have goals yeah so when you accomplish
those goals like what's next
number one overall
okay well we have to be realistic I'm
sure five years ago we said number one
in comedy yeah it was a pipe dream but
then everyone left the Apple charts and
we had it so true we had a fighting
chance in hell I think we would never be
number one in comedy if Joe Rogan was on
Apple charts no because he was like he
was one two three four five yeah
smartless wouldn't be one number one no
no I think we all should thank Joe Rogan
yeah
I think we all should so it's like
number one asterisk doesn't count I mean
it doesn't matter I think we still have
goals I agree number one overall okay
number one in shows we were number two
in shows yesterday
so it's just exciting some news about us
which we never talk about so it's nice
to finally just like be able to to
splurge it is and we are back together
in the Florida Studio everyone if you're
watching on YouTube flamingos
abound abound and they're gorgeous they
held up nicely in our time away it's so
good to be back to have Bryce Thrice
how are you enjoying your time here so
far I'm enjoying it and I say I have
been kicked out of my room which is fine
I'm at the other guest room it's it's
gorgeous actually kind of like this one
better it's very peaceful and uh
isolated isolated which I would like but
I know you'd like to be around people
but I'm also feeling like you're kind of
in your like loner era right now no not
only that statistic not only that
there's something about being in a house
that like freaks me out I think just
like living in a house is
just scary yeah you know like so many
sounds so many things and
the the placement of my room is kind of
like at the the end of the house like if
somebody were to come in and kill
everyone like I really would be the last
person there might be enough time for me
to climb out the window agreed and I
slept soundly knowing that you know
feeling that you guys were dead
downstairs and I was like totally fine
upstairs yeah but it doesn't keep you up
at night like worrying about your loved
ones downstairs yeah it didn't
that's great did you sleep good I slept
great you know you slept on a thuma bed
I could tell the toasty Spirit was with
me that's why I slept so well and
bowling brand sheets of course I knew
that I knew that yeah but eventually the
room Claudia was MLB my primary guest
room so I'm gonna beef it up a little
bit starting with that mini fridge that
I left for you it was so cute I haven't
used yet I just wanted to give you like
a little something special because I've
been booted yeah no it felt good if not
everyone like doesn't have a lot of
amenities
that's enough yeah it's Bare Bones yeah
it has a TV it's because I haven't like
put money into it because everything
from the other guest room will be going
into that guest room so there's no point
you're not explain yourself Jax you're a
great hostess thanks I'm trying
um this is me trying oh nice
and what else we had a lovely barbecue
last night at my place I had an amazing
hot dog that I've just been wanting hot
dogs obviously since I gave birth and
I've had a few but when you ordered a
hot dog from delivery like you don't
they're not very good it's honestly like
you shouldn't be allowed to order a hot
dog but it satiates
crazy gets the job done until I could
get back home and get some a h dogs on
the grill grape upon sauerkraut so good
so good it was so nice to eat like a big
meal
like with family like even when I have a
home-cooked meal at my house it's not
the same you know something about like
being at a table with your nurse with
your entire family fresh food from the
grill like there's something better the
entire family stands Ben I mean so true
I keep forgetting this out here that's
maybe why I slept so good like knowing I
was full of love laughter light and
family and food and togetherness and the
food of course
but mostly the togetherness yeah and did
you not take NyQuil also maybe that's
why you slept good I did I did yeah so
that's probably why you slept good
probably
and so we have a lovely weekend I think
I'm gonna cook a brisket today oh yeah I
actually kind of inspired Jackie would
you say you did because there's two even
though if the meal comes out bad it's
not my fault there's two nights of Rosh
Hashanah Olivia like just assumed the
mantle she was like I'll do both nights
Jackie you have so much on your plate
like you can't worry about not just like
cooking but hosting plating dishware you
know it's two dishwasher Cycles when
you're hosting like that Olivia has two
dishwashers she does I only have one
it's so underrated you only have one
yikes I know but it's like where's such
a crazy thing you have two dishwashers
it is but it's they like they use
they're both always fall but it's and
I'm sure my dishwasher is always empty
but I'm sure if I had to like they would
still not be enough and it's weird
because I have a home and I have a big
kitchen but I don't have space for a
second dishwasher who does I barely have
space for an ice machine it's the
craziest thing counter space I guess
because I have all those bottles
Contraptions yeah like once the baby
brezza right be a nice machine the
drying rack right
so anyways I would like to live I really
did want to try and do one night in my
home the second night because the first
night's the big night where everyone's
like really excited and Olivia's night
is obviously gonna have like the better
spread don't say that Jack but like I
got this like huge dining table that
fits the whole family and I've never
we've never really been able to sit
around it except for last night which
was amazing we have to Chris in the home
with the Jewish Spirit right and I was
like you know what I really want to have
everyone by me so Claudia sent me a
recipe for a brisket I got a cookbook
I've never had a cookbook before now I
know like why you like them I feel so
like oh let me describe my cookbook
obsessed it's Jake Owen's new one it's
called I could Nosh it's like all Jewish
and I wasn't really planning on opening
it because I don't cook then I saw on
his Instagram he made one of the recipes
like to promote his cookbook and it was
the brisket and don't lie like it looked
so good right it did I don't know
but don't you know like the brisket
looked good but like I don't know um
that's what I'm making yeah but how how
can you know until you make it it looked
good it looked good so once we get our
hands on it like who knows no I will
follow that recipe too that's what I do
I'm gonna have you reading it like over
and over again because you sent me
pictures of it yeah I should have just
brought it totally duh we're so dumb or
maybe it's online I can print it maybe
I'll just text him ask for like a PDF
yeah okay yeah so I'm excited but it
calls to be like cooled overnight so I'm
gonna be starting today but that's
actually better for my schedule that way
I can spread things out because I don't
want to be overwhelmed tomorrow so
important to spread them constantly
constantly
so it's gonna be a fabulous weekend
we're gonna kick off the weekend with a
nice bit of toast which is
kind of the best way to start a weekend
in my opinion and a year end a year yeah
yeah yeah so we wouldn't let you start
your year without a bit of toast to set
the tone for the year so before we do
that let's just wish everyone a shout
out to about um you have a sweet New
Year a fabulous holiday weekend and if
you're not impacted by the holidays
neither is the toast because we'll be
back on Monday and if you're not
impacted by the holidays like just have
a wonderful fall weekend maybe you're
picking up maybe you're making a
cauldron of money
that's nice cider yours is better mulled
wine no that's good no exciters yeah
so happy fall weekend we're falling
actually no it's still not fall I know
that's like the crazy thing about summer
it's like Labor Day well I'm wearing all
white because it's still summer no it's
like September is mostly summer yeah so
summer summer but before we get into
everything I have something to say I I
have a couple things to say and she is
so lost she is that's what you sounded
like she is lies and that's me and what
I have to say is that today's episode is
brought to you by Dreamland baby we've
spoken about Dreamland baby on the toast
a couple times now but for The Mamas out
there aunties caretakers whoever you are
this is the baby product that you need
to know about because Dreamland baby has
their Dreamland baby weighted swaddle
the weighted swaddle is amazing for the
Bebes so I found out about Dreamland
like after Harry was out of the newborn
phase but I tried I wanted to try all
these different swaddles because he was
having issues sleeping and the Dreamland
swaddle was just Supreme a wonderful
wonderful addition it's like the way
that you feel using a gravity blanket
right and the anxiety that it takes away
and it's just relaxing and calming like
that's what the Dreamland uh baby
swaddle does for your baby because it is
weighted and now with Charlie I was so
excited to try it with a newborn because
like that's when you need all the help
you can get while sleeping and what I
love about the Dreamland baby weighted
swaddle is that it has three different
ways that the baby can wear it arms in
one arm out or both arms out and one
thing about Charlie is he does not want
his arms in so I need a swaddle that's
gonna like give me the weight adoption
but also the arms out option and the
Dreamland baby weighted swaddle is the
one that does that it really calms him
and it's just so nice they also they
come in gorgeous colors really nice
material because with the newborns like
you don't want to be putting them in
materials that are not going to be
wonderful for them so if you go to
dreamlandbabyco.com and enter our code
toast at checkout you will receive 20
off site wide plus free shipping this
offer is for new and existing customers
so get 20 off of the Dreamland baby
weighted swaddle it is a wonderful baby
product
also for the mamas out there today's
episode is brought to you by Poise Ultra
thins becoming a mom has come with a lot
of big changes and with baby number two
the changes just come in keep it coming
I'm coming so I've talked about Poise
before and they're Ultra thins because
they are the best way to contain bladder
leaks yes a wonderful Joy of postpartum
life our bladder leaks and actually I
tested the Poise ultra thin pads
in a way that they've never been tested
because I put one on when my water broke
and I wore it all the way to the
hospital and my water kept on breaking
so more than just a bladder leak like
gushes if you know you know and that
Poise pad kept me all the way to the
hospital didn't leak in the Uber like
the driver would have had no idea that
the city was in labor except for the
fact that she was mostly reverting the
whole time so the Clean dry and fresh
protection these pads provide is a
lifesaver and they're shaped to flex and
fit with your body so you can stay
comfortable and live without compromise
Poise Ultra thins offer with and without
wings so you can live worry free are you
a Wings girly or without wings I'm
without wings oh I kind of like a wing I
have my reasons I won't share but I have
my reasons I have my reasons too These
Wings Were Made to Fly
so I love my poise you have enough on
your plate as a mama so I love the idea
of taking one thing off the list it
takes boys learn more at poise.com and
check out their Ultra thins you guys if
you know you know if i y k y k
now I'm ready oh okay good now that I've
served The Mamas their content and the
advertisers right I'm ready first up
Irina Shake is playing the field with
Tom Brady and she's in a bit of a love
triangle with Tom Brady and Bradley
Cooper
I can't Irina shake it according to page
six Irina Shake is playing the field
with Tom Brady but she still wants to
settle down with Brad Cooper
you guys are on the nickname basis yeah
Brad I call him Brad just me and Brad me
and Brad and Irina and Tom Right Tom I
call him Timmy I call her ree the
supermodel has been spending time with
both her on again off again flame
Bradley Cooper as well as the retired
NFL stud Tom Brady as the part of the
world's best looking love triangle
literally sax A source told paychecks
when it comes to Cooper vs Brady Irena
is still hoping to tie the knot and
settle down with Bradley Cooper with
whom she shares a six-year-old daughter
years have been put into the
relationships as a source and they were
just spotted together on a family
vacation in Italy with the topless photo
shoot and earlier this month she was
spotted with Tom Brady so she there
could be nothing here and she's just
co-parenting with her ex right but the
way that I see it no I could definitely
see this being the reality is that she
still holds a torch for Bradley I think
she likes Tom he's probably a nice guy
and he's very good looking but I think
the best part of him is that he might
make Bradley jealous right and like
she's a family with Bradley I'm rooting
for Bradley and Irina like I'm rooting
for a family to remain together I am too
but like ever since I believe it was you
who opened my eyes to like page six's
obsession with making Irina Shake look
like a loser I I see like this through
that lens too like wow she's going to
really far Lanes just to make like her
ex-boyfriend jealous
um to be honest like I can't imagine
anyone in the world no matter who you
are dating Tom Brady like for revenge
like if you get a it's like win a date
with Chad Hamilton win a date with Tom
Brady like you don't just give that up
no but they're just playing in a
different League that's true it's not
like she left one league and entered
another it's true and Bradley Cooper's
in that League too and so is she like so
it's just this is what like regular
people do on the ground every day who
would you rather date
I think Tom Brady
who would you rather date
I don't know you know I don't it's a
true dangerous choice I don't know
either man that well I'm just talking
about looks pretty much because we don't
know them
oh they're like both equally handsome to
me I think it just depends it's like
Bradley Cooper is he Chris Kyle Bradley
Cooper that's true I think I would
choose Bradley Cooper because I feel
like Tom Brady got some plastic surgery
like did you see what he's been looking
like recently like he kind of looks like
a girl like he looks like he got like
lip filler and a chin filler and he's
still really handsome but like he's not
as handsome as he once was I'm just
saying okay one of my favorite things to
do is to like criticize beautiful
people's looks it makes me feel better
about myself I understand no there's
anybody else like see like what I'm
talking about she like kind of looks
like a Kardashian like I actually do
he's just looking like shiny and now and
it's not my favorite look well maybe the
It'll like dissolve it needs to settle
it'll settle in his face yeah and maybe
he would go out with him I guess he like
returned to the field for the Patriots
like opening game and he like shook his
hoodie off and had a Patriots jersey on
so everybody was like screaming in the
arena for the Patriots jersey and I was
just looking at the filler I'm like you
look full
let me go look at what you're talking
about Patriot oh my God it's Googling
Tom Brady Patriots Yeah like you have to
you have to find the photo from like a
few days ago he makes an emotional
return to me anyway yeah yeah and it was
emotional for me because I'm like what
happened to your face oh I do see he
just like he got a little nip and tuck
in my opinion yeah
and so that's why I'm choosing Bradley
who do you think has more money Tom
yeah but who do you think has better
personality
Bradley I feel like they both suck no I
feel like Bradley Cooper has a cool
personality you did I feel like if Tom
Brady saw Bradley Cooper in the smart
list doc not to platform right because
they're over parties because there are
competition uh but if he could be on a
comedy podcast right and he can hang
with those guys I also feel like if Tom
Brady had this incredible personality
personality we would know I feel like
footballers who have good personalities
like it always shines through yeah no
they get hosting gigs right they're you
know in movies Kelsey Brothers yeah and
he made a movie like with his
personality and it was 80 for Brady and
you said it's Tonk it up
so I just feel like if he had this
boisterous outgoing effort that's in
Personnel we would know it's so true
he's been on TV for like 20 years it's
so easy for athletes to shine through
when they have like
a good personality I feel like it
happens all the time when I feel like
ESPN is always looking for athletes with
personality right and so many Clips go
viral they mic up the players they have
little End Zone dances I've never seen
that from Tom
he's a serious guy I also like a serious
guy sometimes you could be both I could
be both yeah I have to choose right and
you are both like you're literally the
definition of serious and fun
dirty to like find you a guy who can do
both thank you
it's the truth today what a great year
this is how we're starting the roast yes
this is how we're starting the year
so who shall Irina choose if this is
irina's Choice the person she has a a
child with but like if it hasn't worked
out in the past like there's obviously a
reason and I this is gonna be mean and
maybe just because like I'm feeling like
being a [__] but like I think Irena and
this is just how I perceive it like I
mean like he doesn't like you like if he
wanted to he would like you literally
have a child together Irina if he wanted
to he would I mean it get over it but
sometimes it does take like a man seeing
you know what right it could be without
you I understand and like I feel like he
I feel like and this is again just pure
speculation I just think she's acted
over the last few years like since they
broke up like kind of desperate like to
get back together with him and that's
not like an attractive look so maybe
this is like her playing hard to get and
maybe it is the thing that works and
gets them back together I just feel like
if all this time it hasn't worked like
why no why now why this Brady Brady but
maybe it is the Brady that'll that'll do
it maybe it is maybe it is but I don't
think so okay we shall see you know
pages will keep us posted yeah and
irina's like losery becomings and goings
even though she's probably like in
reality like the most competent cool
person that has both these guys like
Bradley's begging to get back with her
but paychecks will never let you know
that no they'll say she's chasing Tom
Brady around her wedding right so right
right she's planning these trips with
Bradley to like
she posts the pictures of them on her
social media because she wants to get
back together she thinks the public
pressure like page six is doing this
girl so dirty and let me just say like
I'm eating it up like I'm buying
everything they're selling
well speaking of buying things that
other people are selling Demi Lovato has
a new album out and it's a revamped
version yeah her classic song she
doesn't have a new album out as rock
anthems well it's yeah no it's the
greatest hits like it's called revamp
though and she transforms 10 of her
greatest hits into Brash Anthem so she
decided to re-record her old music after
famously holding a funeral for her pop
career last year I don't know about
famously famously I never heard of it I
don't even know she did that I didn't
hear about it either that was ahead of
her first Punk record holy favuck but
unlike you know Taylor's versions that
don't sound any different these songs
completely reinvent her signature songs
with grittier instrumentation punchier
Melodies and even some updated lyrics so
in the original version of 2015 school
for the summer it featured a line that
said don't tell your mother but now she
says go tell your mother
on the revised mix of tell me you love
me where it says you ain't nobody till
you got somebody she added the words
they say you ain't nobody till you got
something empowering to remind fans
empowering remind fans that it's okay to
be alone no for sure thank you dummy
um
cool like okay first of all Demi songs
the ogs are the best excellent so I'm
here for a revamp version I just love
when people are like let me tell you how
much I respect this like
holy [__] I'm unfamiliar with it like
sometimes making new music like isn't
the right path for you you know that's
what I'm saying I feel like Miley went
through that too we're like she just
kept making new music like trying to
find her sound and she eventually did
find it but then briefly she went back
and started like singing start all over
in the climb and I was like you know
what it's good yeah I would love an
album like this for Miley and I just
want to say as a concept in general I
love this idea yeah especially from like
girls who made music so young yeah and
it's like those are still amazing songs
but like you might not relate to the way
that they sang it or their voice might
have been you know yep younger and
higher or just like old production and
it needs a revamp right so I think I
would love to see this trend more I
think Demi is a great person to be doing
it because she has so many great songs
that could be punched up no and rock
click is a good
um genre for demi it's funny I feel like
when Miley was like searching for her
sound she tried everything and then rock
is really where she ended up too it's
more like it's less like obvious Rock
it's more like edgy like you know in
indie rock but Demi really does have
like a good rock Vibe oh did you see she
was on Howard Stern Making Waves yeah
that cool for the summer is about like a
Trish she had with a famous woman yes
but she won't say who it is now because
she's in a relationship right and she
feels it would be disrespectful no I
have theories oh
it's gonna be crazy
but I felt on obviously a Tic Tac Tick
Tock Rabbit Hole
um I feel like it was Katy Perry
that's so funny I thought you were gonna
say that but ideally yeah I don't know
why maybe because she has a similar song
I Kissed a Girl so you just kind of like
associate the tube I don't think I
kissed a girl's about Demi but I think
like no I'm sorry that's not even why
because I guess people like didn't know
that Katy Perry is bisexual even though
she has like said it in interviews and
then recently she was uh she literally
had a song I Kissed a girl right and
then recently I was like when Demi came
out to her parents like I'm bisexual and
they were like you have a song cool for
the summer like we know oh wait how was
cool for the summer about girls
um don't tell your mother it's about a
girl we're Queen in the summer like if
you read all the lyrics oh I never put
that together yeah that's what she said
on Howard oh I only watched the uh
clickbaity part
um but Katy Perry my click baby part was
a longer clip right Katy Perry was
recently photographed with Fletcher like
in a very um you know sensual pose and
then she was in this other photo with
like a bunch of other queer women and
she was you know kind of dressed looking
like a lesbian so everyone was like wait
Katy Perry's bye and then they found
this clip she's like yeah bye like it's
not a secret so that's why I just feel
like it's Katie even though I have no
other proof I feel like the age
difference might not make sense yeah
when Demi wrote cool for the summer
actually I guess she would have been
like 23-ish that's when because I'm the
same age as Demi I mean it literally
could have been anyone could have been
anyone but also we should look at who
which women Demi has dated publicly to
like see if she has a type and then
maybe we could that work backwards and
perhaps we should actually watch the
entire interview with Howard to know if
the woman's closeted like is this a
person we know is out she didn't say in
the clip I saw right but she did say the
woman doesn't know the song is about her
doesn't answer my question like because
if it's a closeted woman no we'll never
guess I feel like then she would have
said
this person is closeted yeah like I'm
not saying who it is because they're
closeted because she said she the person
doesn't know the song is about them and
she wouldn't tell them at this point
because she's in a relationship so right
at no point did she say it was because
she was closing at no point in the clips
that we saw
in no point in the one minute clip out
of a three-hour injury that we saw did
she say that right so she must have not
said it I will say she did look very
very good on that interview like happy
healthy she looked well she looked well
exactly and I'm happy for her yeah she
looks like the little Demi she looked
like old Demi like just she just gotta
return to your rooms yeah she looked
good I'm happy but sometimes you have to
go
in order to come home I mean that's so
Malibu by Miley there's actually a lot
of similarities in Miley and Demi's
Journeys yeah but it's even like
traveling sometimes like you know you
need to leave your house in order to
miss it if that's the truth and that's
how she feels getting back to her roots
that'll be the name of her next album
Roots Roots is a good word it is you
know I was thinking about Olivia
Rodriguez we had this conversation once
about the words in this studio on our
last episode of the Year growth right
with Olivia Culpo the one that Olivia
was on
yeah because we were talking about the
end of the year
makes you think makes you think but that
would be a good name for an album yeah
and Olivia Rodrigo does four letter
word albums
no it doesn't work root yeah root less
than Roots Roots greater than root root
I don't give a root
I don't
I really don't give a root so I will be
listening to this album
okay good I will be if I can find the
time she performed at the VMAs so we got
uh she did like a little medley she did
heart attacks yeah and like she was did
that performance was everywhere everyone
was dancing everyone was loving it like
yeah go back to the class this is a good
ERA for demi like I'm really happy for
her yeah know that I am
even if I honestly can't understand that
is a demi song yeah I know I wonder if
she revamped that one
I'm ha what song is it it's
um
even if I can understand
I'll take the blame you take the truth
be in my heart happier we'll make it
through
if happy is her I'm happy for you by the
way the songs on the album revamped
heart attack great confident oh sorry
not sorry yuck oh actually terrible she
posted the uh rock cover like little
snippets on Tick Tock it sounded pretty
good okay but the song itself yeah is
bad cool for the summer amazing tell me
you love me
I really forgot how many Bops Demi had
Neon Lights sing it like me online
look I don't know that song no you do
it's about okay it's like from a heart
attack era okay skyscraper
challenging
La La Land
it's like no surprise she got uh like
Disney's approval like that was an old
like a deep cut yeah give your heart a
break
so good and don't forget did you oh that
song so good so good that's one of the
best songs ever made yeah
wow congrats Demi congrat me
are you ready for our next story I am
Joe manganello leaves the gym with an
actress 13 years his Junior amid his
divorce with so we literally said
because he wants kids he's gonna get
with someone younger
yeah we said that right and we said if
he got with someone younger that would
give Credence to the rumor that he
they're divorcing because yeah even
though like men in Hollywood go with
younger women all the time they don't
want
um kids they're just disgusting so yeah
yeah yeah Joe manchinello was spotted
leaving a sweaty gym session with much
younger actress Caitlin O'Connor less
than two months after filing for divorce
from his wife Sophia Vergara the two who
have a 13-year age difference looked
giddy on Wednesday as they exited Gold's
Gym in Venice California and walk side
by side in photos obtained by Page Six
exclusive how old is Joe mangionello
he is 46 and she's 33 so that's like not
crazy it's not crazy they both have
fully formed
they can make theirs
yeah it's real it's actually really hard
to see someone living your dream
no but oh and now that they're at the
gym it really is your dream well okay
relax
um the thing is oh my God Joe mangelo is
like one of the hottest people I've ever
met in my life never met him and two you
know if they're going on dates to the
gym like they're close no and they've
been together for a long time right
because like you don't show someone
makeup free sweat like you know pit
stains but some girls like just don't
worry about those things you know like
some girls no they do no she also
appears to be wearing leggings from
Booty by Bray bands a former sponsor of
the toast great leggings yeah they make
your ass look nice
um this is tough it makes you look very
like good and young okay but it just
makes me wonder now because if you're
comfortable being spotted out with
someone two months after you got
divorced and it's not like they're on a
dinner date where it could be a first
date like this is obviously a
relationship like were they dating it's
a good question before there was a
divorce filed also another good question
is who goes to Gold's Gym I feel like
that's a gym franchise of the 90s like
the early 2000s it's just not very like
Hollywood but it's a regular person yeah
it's giving like Planet Fitness it's
getting regular yeah Joe does feel like
a regular guy he does and I feel like
he's the type of guy who like wants to
go to the gym to be at the gym and not
you know for their juice bar and their
sauna and their amenities yeah amenities
like he's going for the dumbbells and I
think it looks like I mean it shows I
feel like gold has good dumbbells and
equipment I think it's a fair assessment
they gave the heavy duty equipment I
just feel like Gold's like branding and
like their t-shirts literally a guy with
a bench press it's very early 2000s I
didn't even know that they still existed
yeah
but that their whole thing is like a guy
with a bench press like you go to do you
say what Jim you go to
I don't I think I have I go to Equinox
like I don't think that's I think that's
like yeah like is that crazy like I go
to Equinox and there's like a juice bar
and like I've never been to the juice
bar or the shop the shop is really a
highway robbery stay away from it like
it's so cute what do they have in the
bathrooms there the bathrooms are what
really for me is like what's fabulous
first of all there's a pool and a cold
plunge I haven't been yet though
actually they have a spa
they had uh and you got a massage and I
got a facial it was excellent uh they
have uh steam room sauna Keels products
amazing blow dryers I do need to talk to
someone though about their scrunchie
offerings it's not gonna work
if anybody at equinox like wants to talk
you need like a schoonchi sponsorship
and you need like an Athena Club razor I
cut the [__] out of my legs with those
razors like that's not cool well then
everyone would steal them everybody
steals [__] there anyway people
literally come with their empty um Keels
face cream and they just use the face
cream like that's what you're paying for
it's that's true it's a small tub yeah
no I'm sorry like scrunchies and razors
they need to be top tier for equinox
like somebody somebody get in touch with
me because you need Athena club and you
need
literally any brand like the scrunchies
are not gonna work okay okay I have
notes
much like I do with Bloomingdale's and
now I do with Equinox feel free to get
in touch
so oh also did you see that like Sofia
Vergara she's a judge on America's Got
Talent now and like Howie Mandel was
like making jokes about her being single
and they said that she walked off but
like I think it was in all in good fun
um I didn't see that like that's kind of
what's going on with her while I feel
like how we wouldn't make jokes like
unless it was okay yeah he said like she
has a good sense of humor about it but
on the show she like walked off yeah
they're like always making stuff up like
America's Got Talent is the most
scripted like fraudulent show so I'm not
gonna believe anything yeah she was
sitting on a throne of tater tots taking
a lie detector test excuse me
you heard what I said
I don't think that I did she was sitting
on a throne of tater tots taking a lie
detector test yeah that's what I read
speaking of tater tots what are we
having for lunch
oh that's a great great question I'm
happy to order you anything that you
want I personally am in my turkey
sandwich era and I have turkey and I've
seen to grow up like for all you need to
grow up with the turkey sandwich like
what are you 12. what do you want for
lunch wench
what sounds better for lunch than a
homemade turkey sandwich you know what I
ended up on the side of like really
crazy no I'm making you soup no soup no
I really don't want and also like
Olivia's making soup for dinner so I'll
have soup for dinner okay so what do you
want for lunch I really want Raising
Canes but they don't have that here do
they they don't even have it in New York
oh and what would you get like fried
chicken the chicken tenders have Fried
Chicken it's like chicken tenders okay
fried chicken and like Texas toast like
like I'm really I've just been craving
it because so many people on my Tick
Tock have been eating it can I think I'm
raising canes in Florida
no but we have other good um chains
chains but I haven't really ventured out
into the fast food here we do have to do
it fast at some point but I don't think
we'll have time this weekend sounds like
we need to do it in the Box you can get
to know your surroundings that we 100
shelf the idea uh
but that's not how we want to start the
year even though eating fast food in our
cars like that doesn't bode well for the
year for like our health Journeys that
we're on yeah
I guess but would be the worst thing no
we'd be happy
are you ready for our next story a story
what story is invested in number four oh
no I'm not ready oh my God that flew by
you better get right it's crazy how fast
mediocre stories can just it's crazy
they just zoom past you well these are
some these mediocre stories are in fact
brought to you by Jenny Kane so support
for today's show comes from Jenny Kane
which is perfect timing honestly because
fall is on its way we were just talking
about that chili season mulled wine
season cider season Jenny Kane season
our wardrobes definitely needed a
refresh and Jenny Kane is a California
brand through and through their Staples
make getting dressed easier than ever
think middle-less minimalist and
effortless but totally refined from
luxurious cashmere sweaters and iconic
accessories to elevated versions of all
your everyday Basics not to mention the
most incredible Home Essentials too
Jenny Kane is here to help you live your
best season yet and for a limited time
our listeners are getting 15 off their
first order when they go to
jennycame.com and using Code toast at
checkout
um I have to say like if you are looking
for like fall Nancy Myers grandma what
do they call it Coastal grandmother
energy like Jenny Kane is a store for
your home for your wardrobe for you I
have fabulous sweaters that like pair
well with everything that really just
give me like my Coastal grandmother
aesthetic perfectly her candles make my
home very Coastal grandmother she has
really great home accessories really
great
um wardrobe Staples so sweaters are the
ID item and we are obsessed with the
Flynn cashmere sweater from Jenny Kane
it is a perfect everyday v-neck and the
cashmere Francis Polo is such a cool
vintage inspired staple they're back in
new shades and you can bet that we're
adding them both to our car to ASAP we
get compliments every time we wear our
Jenny cane items they're so comfortable
we can live in them all season long and
I've had my one of my favorite Cardigans
from Jenny Kane for like three Winters
now and they last really well they get
better with time they're really soft
they really start to like mold to your
body
um they're known for super Luxe yet
lightweight sweaters so trust us the
cashmere is better than anyone's they
have incredible Rewards program too
where you can earn up to 10 back with
every purchase and joining is completely
free so find your Forever pieces at
jennykane.com our listeners can get 15
off their first order when you use code
toast at checkout that 15 off your first
order at
j-e-n-n-i-k-a-y-n-e.com promo code toast
let getting dressed be one less thing to
worry about at jennycane.com promo code
toast for 15 off your first order
thank you Claudia you're welcome oh my
God I almost forgot my bad our next
story Aaron Rodgers undergoes surgery
for his torn Achilles heel and thanks
doctors for starting him on the road to
recovery and thanks Taylor Swift for
everything she's done as he always does
every day when he says his morning
prayers yes when he says his state of
grace
the quarterback revealed is an Instagram
story posted the underwent surgery to
repair his left Achilles he healed that
was torn during the New York Jets game
against the Buffalo Bills on Monday he
said surgery went great thank you for
all the love and prayers and support and
thanks to the goat doctor and his staff
for starting me on the road to recovery
okay I have so much to say the first is
I was in scrimpost and I left a comment
like
hope that you listen to State of Grace
and like The Toasters understood it but
like these footballers that were sending
me like literally hate mail engagement
no they were literally sending me death
threats I
think about his recovery like I know
nothing of course about football nor
medicine but I have a really good
feeling yeah I I just feel like and this
is what one of the analysts said in the
story that I read which was that like
he's not going to let this be the way
that his football career ends I believe
that because I know Aaron he's a fighter
yeah he's a
fighter I also think he should watch
Country Strong during his recovery
because he kind of is like Country
Strong yeah is giving him strength right
and he's a person who values strength
and Country he does you see him with the
flag right so I think he's a strong man
that's what I'm saying I do really feel
like it might benefit him to watch that
movie we should make him a list of like
feel good content music TV shows love
Island season five things to watch to
speed up his recovery
we should just have that list in general
which we do try and have it's all
sleepover synonymous with our like
family trip movie list right honestly
drop a comment like what's a feel-good
movie TV show or song that you would
recommend Aaron Rodgers to listen to to
speed up his recovery of his Achilles
heel you know what song I like as a
feel-good song but I don't know if it
relates to Aaron yeah it's you can't
stop the Girl by Bebe rexha from the
Maleficent soundtrack love that I have
another song Too brokenhearted no no
that would be mean because broken heart
is a song I think you should use when
you're working out and he can't work out
um no it's that song and I wonder is
Aaron Rodgers a man of faith I have to
assume I feel like he probably I'm sure
he has a long answer about it right
something where he believes in a higher
being so yes
um and I think you should listen to that
song by Britt Nicole
that plays at the end of The Other Woman
which is also another feel-good movie
that he should definitely listen to such
a feel-good movie yes how does that song
Go the sun is rising the Sun is
and that bridge where Leslie Mann throws
her ring into the ocean added to the
list
I feel like I actually never bring that
up especially in regards like in
relation to how beautiful it is I feel
like I never bring it up a couple times
what I wonder how many times before it
makes the list
five
no well five five in how many years I
feel like fine I definitely said Britt
Nicole Story five times over the last
literally five years okay is that a lot
no once a year no
no fine once a year that's your max oh
God so I can't bring that up for a whole
other year that's all next versus Shawna
okay fine so let me talk about it a
little bit more the bridge of that song
is so good How does it go
um when you can't you know it's like
yeah yeah yeah you know what let's
pull it up even if it wins lose it you
know wait let me just oh don't joke I
could just pull up the line we don't
even monetize our videos oh yeah pull it
up pull it up pull it up pull it up
oh if you know you know Skip to the
bridge or no we're gonna listen to
Hillsong we'll literally get taken down
off of YouTube okay right we just can't
monetize
I'm just feeling like I'm in Aaron's
head right now put it closer to the mic
I'm worried
literally
bringing New York back jet Super Bowl
win
right
you're gonna make it Aaron
I believe in you
this is so true
the night can only last for so long
Achilles yell
he's definitely he said my heart is
breaking his heart is broken
there's a promise for the ones who just
hold up I'm gonna cry
someone's calling you
look there is light at the end of the
tunnel Aaron don't worry
the sun is rising
we have time today with these crap
stories okay we didn't even get to the
bridge that was the whole point okay
I'll try and Scoot along
it's coming up now
Bruno's inspired look at him heads up
you're gonna go after Magnolia tell her
how you feel
live
okay here it comes you guys ready
oh
maybe not now yeah
okay yeah here she goes ready she's
about to pop the [__] off Britt Nicole
so Aaron
he's definitely drowning in his doubt
right now just look beyond the clouds
just look beyond the clouds just look
beyond the clouds Aaron it's gonna
happen for you like I really truly
believe that if you don't have chills
you're a monster if you don't have
chills you're a monster get checked yeah
well soon
I'm not done with my iPad in the show we
still have another story yeah we do
was it a bad story why was it just give
us a tldr headline there's some like
janky documentary about the Kardashians
coming out called house with Caitlin
House of Kardashian that Caitlyn has
lent uh her voice too well you okay
sorry it's just kind of no sorry it's
okay it's just yeah let's go go it's
confusing because I remember when
everything happened with Caitlin she
said like that she didn't change her
voice right so it was just like I just
got tripped that was crazy I got tripped
out on The Voice I feel like we're like
as a society like nobody really even
questions no I've never like make sure
you've never done that before it was
just because of the voice of course of
course because the voice is the same the
thing about Caitlyn actually and I think
part of really people refuse to give her
any sort of acknowledgment for being
like a leader in the trans movement is
she's kind of um
like a Pioneer and she's very
um like understanding of like people's
yeah
that's what I'm saying she's not gonna
like be like you misgendered me other
people we're gonna come for mine right
but I actually think the defensive
Caitlyn they might not right because
they don't like kind of this polarizing
figure in the trans Community yeah yeah
and and in the Kardashian Community
because so I think people are like
quaking the cheese it's actually a good
story we could talk about it people are
quaking that she's lending her voice to
this documentary and I actually don't
think it'll be that crazy for the most
part they're on fine terms with her and
she is
Kendall and Kylie's
dad and like even if she might have bad
blood with Chris like Chris is still
their mother I don't think oh my God
Bruno is sleeping oh my God wait don't
move don't move don't move oh [__] he
was literally sleeping standing up are
we boring you bro yeah are you bored
okay
um
I don't think it'll be that damning but
I think it gives the documentary like a
little bit more of you know credibility
because they actually have a Joe Francis
is in it
oh and he's tied with Kim yeah
okay so maybe it's like a approved
project or it's like you were gonna make
this documentary anyway maybe we could
have some friendly faces who have nice
things to say about us right and if they
want to do it they can do it do they say
who else I'm sure it'll be like pop
culture experts reporters you've never
heard of Pop Culture experts um us
quotations around at start
um and who is developing this
documentary Skye oh like Britain yeah
okay so it might be like a more Global
look at the girls because you know we're
very in the weeds yeah that's actually a
good point
yeah it will air in the UK on October
8th
it's giving irrelevant oh for sure but
Caitlyn made it relevant yeah which I'm
sure they hate that yeah for her Caitlin
also made waves
on Twitter this week did you say no
there was a meme going around of I think
I'm sure everyone has seen it like a
restaurant who had men's and women's
bathrooms and the men's picture had a
picture of Bruce Jenner on it and the
women's bathroom had a picture of
Caitlyn Jenner on it and people were
like this isn't funny and Caitlyn
responded actually I think it's funny oh
yeah so Caitlyn's kind of like that's
what I'm saying she wouldn't be mad at
you for accidentally mistaking her
pronouns like she's she's cool yeah no I
I feel okay about that you don't think
Caitlyn's gonna find this and and attack
you no but I do think other people will
attack you but as long as it's not
Caitlin it's not his mistake for sure
like with nothing to hide for sure
that's our show that's our year actually
that's a wrap on five seven four seven I
can never keep up with the Hebrew yeah
me neither
um thank you so much thank you so much
Bruno thank you thank you for making
this episode gorgeous and thank you guys
so much we'll send you the testimony and
thank you to Aaron Rodgers doctors
so true by the way like I really praying
for you this evening yeah
I hope that the start of your year is a
good start me too and for everyone out
there celebrating Rosh Hashanah I hope
you have a meaningful holiday filled
with love and family and food yeah and
sweetness and sweetness it's a sweet
treat thanks for listening
videos
have a great day guys love you I'll see
you Monday bye love you bye